his name is anwar raslan today a german
court sentenced the former syrian
colonel to life in prison for crimes
against humanity prosecutors accused him
of running a detention center for the
assad regime and of overseeing the
torture of 4 000 people including 60
deaths ruslan became a refugee and
arrived here in germany in 2014. he
thought that he had left the civil war
and his dark secret behind him and he
did
for a while but today his past and the
forces of justice
they finally caught up with him
and for reaction to today's sentencing
i'm joined now by kenneth rothy the
executive director for human rights
watch kenneth it's good to have you back
on
the day you and i have spoke numerous
times about efforts to bring justice to
those who who have and who continue to
commit war crimes and crimes against
humanity in syria how important is
today's sentencing of anwar
rosslyn
this is a truly historic moment it's the
first
judgment of its sort and to put this in
perspective the assad government in
syria has pursued this war really
through a war crime strategy that's been
the entire way they fought the war they
have deliberately bombed hospitals and
schools and marketplaces they've used
chemical weapons against their own
people
they've used starvation as a method of
war and the issue here in this
this trial was the pervasive use of
arbitrary detention torture and indeed
thousands of executions now
the assad government denies all of this
the obvious place to have held a trial
would have been the international
criminal court but syria never joined
the court and the only route to the
court then would have been through the
u.n security council which russia and
china blocked with their veto
so
a number of governments germany included
helped to circumvent the veto and the
u.n security council by going to the u.n
general assembly and getting it to
create what's known as the international
independent impartial mechanism or the
triple i m for syria which is um
basically a prosecutor without
jurisdiction so there is today a french
prosecutor sitting in geneva collecting
evidence of these atrocities and and
making it possible for you know a
prosecutor in a a small town like
koblenz to pursue a case like this
because in fact there are now reams of
records about the atrocities about the
chain of command and so um it is
possible to exercise this concept of
universal jurisdiction that is to say
you know the ability to pursue things
like war crimes crimes against humanity
torture in any available court
that becomes more possible now because
of this repository of evidence sitting
in geneva that was an important part of
the trial of koblenz and this is now an
historic step forward an actual fair
trial and a conviction and kenneth what
you're saying is that we would maybe
have
you know gotten to this verdict earlier
we would be seeing even more trials
if it weren't for china and russia
standing in their way
are you saying that they are protecting
war criminals inside of syria
well it's worse than that i mean yes
china's protecting war criminals russia
is participating in the war crimes if
you look at the bombing today or until
quite recently of the hospitals and the
schools and the markets and the
apartment buildings um more often these
days that's russian jets rather than
syrian jets so you know russia is
completely a partner in the crimes of
the air war you know russia isn't as
present on the ground for the kind of
torture that was the focus in koblenz
but russia has a direct you know
personal interest in avoiding
accountability for these war crimes
because it is an active participant in
these crimes why aren't we calling them
out there more at the human security
council for example
well the u.n security council can't
speak
because of the russian veto
so it is it's been in fact very
difficult even for the security council
to authorize cross-borders humanitarian
assistance from turkey into the parts of
syria still held by the armed opposition
you know russia very reluctantly goes
along and has gradually been reducing
the entrances to syria down to one um so
but to go beyond that to to bring in the
international criminal court to condemn
the atrocities in syria russia
absolutely precludes that and that's a
real weakness of the structure of the
security council you know the five
permanent members the u.s um china
russia france and britain
each of them has a veto each can prevent
a resolution from going forward they're
not supposed to use this in this kind of
narrow self-interested way they're not
supposed to defend the perpetrators of
mass atrocities but that's exactly what
russia and china have been doing in the
case of syria and elsewhere i should say
places like me
you know more than 2500 miles away from
where we are right now in syria the
misery for millions who are still living
under assad that misery continues and
it's faded a lot from the public's radar
we have to admit that what does today's
landmark court case what does it mean
for those syrians
well you know one important element of
this is there are certain countries
denmark is a good example which want to
pretend that it's safe to send syrian
refugees back to syria because in most
of syria the war is over it's just you
know the assad government back to its
usual repressive ways but you know human
rights watch has done investigations
where we found that you know people who
um go back to syria a relative handful
of people are treated as suspicious just
because they left and they are subject
to the same detention centers the same
torture the same risk of atrocities so
um you know what we saw today in kuwait
the focus of this trial is an ongoing
reality and we should remember this i
mean germany's been very generous in
allowing in syrian refugees but other
countries just can't wait to send them
back and that is completely wrong
because it would be sending them back to
the persecution that was the heart of
this trial
kenneth roth with human rights watch ken
it's always good talking with you
valuable valuable context to help us
understand what's what continues to go
on inside and outside of syria thank you
thank you